[Music]
in my conversations with the president
and the administration he has been very
consistent on wanting transparency and I
have not seen a major pushback on this
request as long as it protects sources
and methods Bruce or had told the key
people at the FBI that Kris Steele the
author of the document was desperate to
stop Trump from being elected they knew
the ORS involvement both Bruce and
Nellie's involvement in producing that
document they didn't tell the court that
Andy McCabe knew Lisa Paige knew Peter
struck knew and Andrew Weisman a DOJ
knew as well that was congressman mark
meadows and Jim Jordan today calling for
the declassification of russia'
investigation documents that could
reveal big-time corruption at the DOJ
joining me now the affirmation
congressman themselves welcome to both
of you
congressman Jordan the more we learn
about Bruce Orr's contacts with
Christopher Steele that predate what we
believed we talked about months ago now
the timeline has been pushed earlier and
yet his wife worked for the fusion gps
firm did they not know this at the
Justice Department why is this conflict
not flaring across every media outlet
tonight given what we've learned it
should be yeah it should be but you got
a top Justice Department official whose
wife's working for the firm hired by the
Clintons to produce the dossier the
dossier was the key and everyone at the
FBI knew about it Andy McCabe Peter
Straub Lisa page and now we know Andrew
Weisman a key player on Muller's team
knew about it as well how early did he
know they knew about it before they went
to the court the FISA Court that's the
key fact they knew about the ORS
involvement they knew about who paid for
it and they knew what Bruce or told us
that he told the FBI what Christopher
steel said that Christopher steel the
guy who wrote it right was desperate to
stop President Trump from becoming
president and none of this none of this
was in the FISA application congressman
meadows that's correct we don't believe
you no we have not seen the actual the
actual FISA application but from the
footnotes that we have from the memos we
have can it all be declassified well
that's what we're calling all of all of
these yeah listen the American people
need to judge
themselves and we believe that it is
time not a month from now not two months
from now but days from now to declassify
this information show it and you know
what what we believe we're going to see
based on non classified documents is
that information was collected in an
abnormal way it was verified in an
abnormal way and it was prosecuted in an
abnormal way and and all because there
was a bias towards this president and
that information was never presented to
the court which is what they're supposed
to Russia viewed Carter page as an idiot
they didn't think they of course they
want to recruit everybody they tried to
recruit him he's an idiot not really
they didn't put that in the FISA
application either correct that wasn't
there was no red flag about that how do
you get an application to spy on Carter
page when the Russians themselves toss
them to the scientists that's not
someone I will weaken oh and Muller is
not even going after Carter page I mean
here we are two years and we're not
doing it but here's the other thing
and so I shared with you one of the
things that we've recently found out
this is exclusive in a new batch of text
messages is that there was a coordinated
effort by those at the FBI to actually
leaked to the media
we now have documents that prove it
where they leaked to the media then they
use the same information to verify the
veracity of their claims and actually
use that for a FISA warrant well you
can't do both the FBI had a leaked to
the media strategy and it's troubling so
they would leak it so it's like a
circular it's like the game of telephone
it just keeps going around and around so
they leaked to the media
then they cite the media report cite the
media says this is insane yeah but this
is but what are these text messages they
just keep showing up on Dourado
we get all these tools I you know I've
been very critical of the DOJ you know
but they're turning them over now Dave
these are new these are new text
messages that you know we viewed in
in-camera okay so the Soliman report
tonight that again will be reference
Bruce or efforts to secretly reshape
Trump probes started earlier in the
summer of 16 right that's important for
our viewers to understand why well I
think the biggest part of that is is
when it started earlier it was all
supposedly about Papadopoulos now we're
starting to see that it had nothing to
do with george papadapolis it had
everything to do all roads lead to the
dossier that was paid for by the Clinton
campaign and the Democratic National
Committee but there was a footnote in
the FISA application that referenced
some opponent of the president's might
have been most convoluted way to say but
it's worth it not only started earlier
it went after they fired
Christopher Steele he continued to meet
with Bruce or and the FBI continued to
get briefings about those conversations
that Bruce or was having with
Christopher after they got rid of the
Seaforth cotta topic forthcoming behind
closed it was they actually met with
with Steele more times after he was
fired than before he was oh my god this
is I just I want the text messages to
never stop coming okay because every
time we have the text messages
congressman thank you so much for coming
into